traitors tall tales trolls or spies
there is a concerted effort afoot to
take down this presidency we will
analyze who really is the enemy of the
people
in other news Cory Booker is behaving
like an infant again which means it must
be a day that ends in Y then an
abortionist and consulting medical
director of physicians for reproductive
health dr. Ann Davis stops by to discuss
abortion and the Cavanaugh hearings
finally the mailbag on Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
oh do we have a lot to get to today
we've got to start with this anonymous
story but then we're gonna get into more
substantial things the anonymous source
that the New York Times published that
says I'm in the Trump administration I'm
a Trumper
but I'm secretly sabotaging him what if
you found out it was me what if it were
like one day on MSNBC was like I'm I'm
I'm the anonymous source uh hmm look at
me I'm like what's what's Superman's
real name that's it Clark can't be but I
only remember me and Matt out before we
get to any of that I have got to thank a
wonderful advertiser that we have which
is blue apron oh do I love blue apron
blue apron you know this I've told you
about blue apron before it delivers
farm-fresh ingredients and step-by-step
recipes to your door the mission is to
make incredible home cooking accessible
to everyone so the way it works is you
choose these chef's designed recipes you
know don't expect it to be like plain
hamburgers and nothing I mean these are
wonderful recipes really good they're
changing all the times you're not going
to get sick of anything they're gonna
they're gonna be changing these
constantly they deliver fresh seasonally
inspired ingredients which are as good
as they come well the quality of all of
these ingredients is top-notch and is
anybody who cooks ever knows or is
anybody who eats sweet little Elise's
cooking it's all about the ingredients
so the ingredients are really good the
recipes are great you can make dinner in
as little as 20 minutes quick and easy
recipe options insanely good flavors
perfectly portioned ingredients
delivered right to your door so skip all
the meal planning you know you're
sitting there with your wife and like
the argument you have for half an hour
two hours is what you're gonna have for
dinner skip all of that have it
delivered to your door it's really good
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals free get free food
from me don't say I never did nothing
for you blue apron comm slash cough FA
CE o VF e f e if there were ever any
week to gobble up the cough sa it would
be this week blue apron calm slash cough
FA CE o VF e fe get your first three
meals free blue apron a better way to
cook who is the anonymous source the
anonymous source and the New York Times
I'm sure everybody has seen the story
from yesterday the New York Times runs
this piece and they say we have taken
the rare step the unconventional step of
publishing a long essay on the op-ed
pages
anonymously but uh but trust us it's a
senior official in the Trump
administration so you read the article
and I'm sure you've heard it or you've
seen it floating around the internet so
I'll just get to the heart of it Yuri
didn't they say there are people in the
high levels of the Trump administration
who were actively sabotaging the
President's agenda resisting parts of
the President's agenda trying to push
him in directions that he's not trying
to go in and I know cuz I'm one of them
that's the big reveal in the essay and
it talks about how you know is a
conservative guy and that's not like
he's a the resistance on the left but
there is a pact a cabal in the Trump
administration that are actively
undermining president Trump's agenda and
a couple interesting things here the
piece is really poorly written so the
piece is very clumsily put together
it begins in this big reveal on the
resistance and the data and by the end
it just ends up extolling the virtues of
John McCain for a disproportionate
period of time and goes on and on about
McCain and uses all of these tired
cliches and false dichotomies they say
you know country first what what does
country first is only used by people who
have run out of their own ideological
argument or their own philosophical
argument they say country first
what does country first mean what they
really mean when they say that is
country over party but what does that
mean you join a party because you think
the party is putting forth an agenda to
help the country if it's not gonna put
forward the best agenda to help the
country you join a different party
Winston Churchill hot parties back and
forth all the time so these these two
things they seem like they're in
contradiction they're not really in
contradiction the country in the party
are supposed to go together all the time
you know other phrases like that we've
got to put the country first and all of
the John McCain stuff there's one
interesting word here which is lodestar
and this has everyone saying that was
Mike Pence who wrote this which is
absurd nobody seriously believes that
the sitting vice president wrote this
poorly written piece for the New York
Times the main reason I don't think it
was him is because it's not well written
and it says lo you know the lodestar
blah blah blah blah blah people notice
that Mike Pence has used that word
lodestar in a number of speeches over
the years
okay but also the way that these things
work it could easily be somebody using
this keyword that is associated with
pens to kind of frame him and get the
pressure off of themselves there are
three options here there are three cases
for who it is that's the background who
could it be
it's a trader it's a troll or it's a
tall tale those are the three the three
T's of this anonymous essay in the New
York Times it either this person does
exist and he is actually a senior
official and he is actually sabotaging
the Trump administration or it's someone
who is this is coming out of the Trump
administration and they're trying to
troll the New York Times into destroying
their journalistic credibility by
running this outrageous anonymous essay
in the op-ed pages or the New York Times
completely made it up what's the
evidence show are there people who do
this who would actually betray their
employer and betray the Trump agenda
yeah of course President Trump has been
talking about this the whole time
President Trump has been saying there is
a deep state there are embedded
interests in Washington in the
administration working for the
administration who opposed the agenda
that was elected by the American people
in 2016 so we know that that's true
both because this essay was published
and because we've heard about it for so
long and we've seen the evidence of that
it certainly could be the case that this
is all legit and this and this person
really is at the high level and he's
trying to undermine the Trump agenda if
that is the case he's a real traitor to
his country President Trump tweeted out
treason all question question marks all
capital letters and that isn't
overstating the case the American people
did not elect this random staffer who
published in the New York Times they
didn't elect him they didn't elect his
agenda but they're the definition of
tyranny in America would be overturning
the results of a 2016 election would be
undermining the duly elected president
now in all administration's and in all
workplaces you always have the underling
say you know well I could do it better
than him I'm gonna stop my boss from
being so stupid why don't I round so
that happens too but if it is really the
case the president room is not able to
push his agenda through that is
betraying your country because they say
it all the time there we say we
the best of intentions were really
saving the country no you're undermining
the constitutional order there they're
complaining about the Russians
interfering in the election what what is
greater intellectual interference then
trying to overturn the results of a
presidential election and trying to
sabotage the will of the American people
in the constitutional order as expressed
in 2016 so that is really really bad and
that there's nothing noble about it
there's nothing high-minded about it if
at the worse scenario if this is really
the case that this person should be very
ashamed and they should be ferreted out
of the government this is a huge offense
to the American people and a huge threat
to Liberty if it's the worst example now
is it a troll is this a setup for the
New York Times if any president we're
gonna do it it would be Donald Trump
wouldn't he Donald Trump has regularly
referred to the press the the fake news
media as the enemy of the American
people I always thought this was very
little for it was obviously outrageous
very outrageous and just even a little
far for this administration which
thrives on spectacle and thrives on how
rageous statements but if the New York
Times is willing to do this to basically
obliterate any journalistic ethics and
run this this essay anonymously it
actually gives credence to the call the
enemy of the American people the person
writing the essay is bragging about
being an enemy of the American people
that saying the American people elected
this and we're gonna undermine that
constitutional order and do something
different
so it I got to say the reason that the
troll thing kind of hits me is first of
all the president is the greatest troll
in America is he's the master of this I
did the blank book I'm happy to be a
prince of trolls he is the king of
trolls so he certainly could do this and
Donald Trump always makes he always
makes his opponents live up to the
criticisms that he lobbies at them so in
this case if anyone could make the New
York Times live up to the charge of
being the enemy of the people it's Trump
and then the third option is that it's
just fake news now did the New York
Times make this up from scratch I don't
think so I don't think that the op-ed
editor would really risk his reputation
to do something so outrageous and
ultimately something that likely will
come out but what it could be is
that the New York Times is exaggerating
the position of this person so for
they've done this before I think it was
yes there were these emails from a
fracking story that the New York Times
is running was a big article on an anti
fracking article and the New York Times
said we've talked to senior officials
federal officials senior analysts blah
blah blah blah blah
it later came out that their source was
an intern their source it's like the
lowest level staffer you could have even
the New York Times public editor north
of Brisbane said can an intern be an
official doesn't sound right they've
exaggerated this before certainly
possible I'll give you my thought on
this in one second but before let me
make you a little money honey
because we're in a capitalist era we got
to make some money you know about honey
I've told you about this it's the free
shopping tool that finds the best promo
codes whenever you shop online it might
sound too good to be true
so let's go over the facts I used honey
two days ago I was ordering pictures on
the internet and I ordered it I but I
couldn't even tell you it just so
happens I was online shopping a couple
days ago
I use it every time I've used it for
years long before this show existed if
you're not using it you're just missing
out on free money honey has already
saved people over eight hundred million
dollars you might be thinking oh you
know honey doesn't work on the sites
that I shop at it works on thirty
thousand sites it works on eBay Amazon
Walmart Newegg j.crew a lot more so how
is it for house honey free it's because
honey honey gets a small commission from
sites when they save you money so it
just is always free it's it's just a
tremendous product I use it all the time
go to get it right now at join honey
calm / co' FFA CEO of EF EF e it's free
to use installs in just two clicks go
get free money don't be insane get free
money right now join honey calm / go FFA
co v fe fe so that i think is the story
it's it's probably much ado about
nothing it underscores the the claims
that Trump has been making the whole
time and that's why I think any three of
these are plausible that this person
really exists that there actually is
someone trying to sabotage from from
within the government we've been saying
that for months and months and months
that it's a troll that he you know
Donald Trump is getting the New York
Times to
of up to their terrible reputation and
three that the New York Times is just
exaggerating this in their running at
least partially fake news it could be
any of those but what is the take away
what changes with this the guy says
Trump is crazy and stupid and yeah we
don't like him okay does that is that
new is that even news that the that
people around the president don't like
him and underestimate him is that news
now is that New York Times has been
saying this for three years now two or
three years how is that news I don't see
how this moves the needle one bit I
don't see that how this helps Democrats
either because it puts Donald Trump in
the position of underdog and it
validates all of the claims he's been
making about the government about the
press I don't see how this hurts him
perhaps that was the point
perhaps it's perhaps it's either what we
call the three DHS you know the Donald
Trump saw this coming and by 3d chess we
just mean that Donald Trump is good at
manipulating the media which is
obviously true either it is that or it
is just the Trump has this gut instinct
about reality and reality is proving him
right I really want to get to our guest
but before we do that I do have to make
fun of Cory Booker a little bit Cory
let's let's just I'll give you the recap
if you didn't watch all of the hearings
of Brett Kavanaugh
it was the same Cory that we've been
seeing for months and months and months
Cory just give us the summary I hurt
where dick durbin called me I had tears
of rage when I heard about this
experience in that meeting and for you
not to feel that pain hurt and that pain
and to dismiss some of the questions of
my colleagues saying I've already
answered that line of questions with
tens of millions of Americans or hurting
right now
because of what they're worried about
what happened in the White House that's
unacceptable to me unacceptable
unexceptional if he says for you not to
feel that hurt hurt yeah hurt hurts the
line for you not to feel that line line
what was my line again I'm sorry I was I
lost it can we take it from the top can
we can we do this stick again because
he's running for president and he thinks
that whining and screaming like a child
is gonna make him more popular to voters
it'll certainly work with his base so
here is Cory actually at this
today Senator Cornyn actually made a
very good point
I knowingly violated the rules that were
put for and I'm told that the committee
confidential rules have knowing
confident consequences I'm going to
release the email about racial profiling
and I understand that that the penalty
comes with potential outs ting from the
Senate and if senator Cornyn believes
that I violated Senate rules
III openly invite and accept the
consequences of my team releasing that
email right now what I'm releasing this
document right now to show sir is that
we have a process here for a person the
highest office in the land for a
lifetime appointment we're rushing
through this before me my colleagues can
even read and digest the information
running for president is no excuse for
violating the rules of the Senate no
senator deserves to sit on this
committee or serve in the Senate in my
view if they decide to be a law unto
themselves and willingly flout the rules
of the Senate and the determination of
confidentiality and classification that
is irresponsible and conduct unbecoming
a sinner so it's a ridiculous show Cory
is running for president as mr. Cornyn
said right there he's obviously trying
to create a spectacle and he's begging
people to kick him out of the Senate
because that's his only shot right if
there's a big fight about kicking cory
booker out of the senate then he sort of
has a chance to rise up to a tier one
candidate in 2020 but they're not going
to do it he said you released these
emails these these were confidential
emails he wasn't supposed to release
them it really violates the Senate the
rules the sense of collegiality and but
what's funny is the Republicans beat
them to it last night and cleared the
emails for release so Cory didn't even
get to release them and break the rules
and have his big moment
he actually said in the hearing that
this was his Spartacus moment like Cory
man if you if you have to say it it's
not true like this is not a sorry buddy
so just more ridiculous theater from
from the party that is telling us that
they're the mature ones and they're
gonna take the reins just whining and
crying and show
really pathetic and unfortunately for
Cory not gonna help him you're not
getting kicked out of the Senate Cory
I'm sorry - sorry to tell you that okay
we're very lucky to have a guest up here
today you know it's very hard to get
guests from the left and guests who
disagree with our point of view on and
dr. Anne Davis has agreed to join the
program to discuss these Cavanagh
hearings and the role that abortion and
roe v wade is going to be playing in
this and dr. Ian Davis is the consulting
medical director of physicians for
reproductive health and an abortion
provider herself dr. Davis thank you for
being here thank you for the invitation
so dr. Davis before we begin I want your
thoughts on this Cavanaugh hearing and
on the future of abortion politics in
the country I have to begin with the
name of your organization the physicians
for reproductive health because it has
always seemed to me that of all of the
euphemisms that we have in the abortion
debate reproductive health is the most
outrageous one as reproduction and
abortion are diametrically opposed why
is it the case that the abortion
movement the pro-abortion movement
relies on euphemistic and dishonest
language in so much of their political
activity so our name physicians for
Reproductive Health really refers to our
mission which is that we support
comprehensive reproductive health for
everyone so that would include all the
things I do as an ob/gyn contraception
of course and abortion pertinent to this
show but it's really a health
reproductive health concerns all
reproductive health so that's the
explanation for our name but this is the
question I always ask because I'm I'm
not suggesting that being an
obstetrician gynecologist or delivering
babies or any other of the medical
aspects of that position don't concern
reproductive health what what I'm saying
is that it seems bizarre to include
abortion so essentially in this and I'm
not just picking on your organization or
your work but so much in the political
debates we never hear abortion called by
its own name very rarely do we so often
we hear the war on women's health the
war on reproductive health ironically
because it's about the opposite of
but even on Women's Health broadly we're
not you know when I call up my
grandmother I say how you're doing
grandmother she doesn't say well you
know at least I've got my right to an
abortion she says at least I have my
health why is it that uh why is it about
abortion politics that it has to be
lumped within all of these apparently
unrelated medical activities I think
that what is happening there what you've
noticed is that there's a lot of stigma
around abortion as we all know so that
people aren't necessarily comfortable
saying the word abortion or talking
about it
patients absorb that stigma certainly
there's a lot of that in the national
discourse but remember that abortion is
very very common medical care so if you
look at the best numbers we have about
one in four women in the United States
will have an abortion before she's in
menopause so it's a very very common
procedure it's something that is a sort
of a core component of the care that we
provide as ob/gyn so I think you know
there is a little bit of a disconnect
there with how common it is and how
often the word is spoken I agree with
you and I think that's really because of
the stigma and misunderstanding around
abortion of course it is it's very
common in the years after roe v-- wade
was decided the abortion rate nearly
doubled I think it's since then it's
it's dropped dramatically but it there
was a certain certainly an explosion in
the 1970's and early 80's and yet when
we look at the polling and not just from
right-wing forums not just from
religious firms but even left-wing
polling firms like Gallup we find that
the majority of Americans and the
majority of American women in particular
oppose abortion in the second and
certainly in the third terms what does
this mean for the future of abortion
politics so much of the Cavanaugh
hearing has come down to whether or not
he would overturn roe v wade and so much
of the abortion debate happens on you
know what is abortion morally
permissible in the first three hours of
pregnancy or something but what about
those numbers abortion is certainly a
common medical procedure and yet the
majority of Americans oppose it in the
second and third term is there a point
at which the abortion movement will have
to say abortion should not be licit in
the second and the third term is there a
point at which we can say this is no
longer merely a medical procedure that
doesn't involve human beings and is
infanticide I'd like to
so backtrack a bit into into your point
which is to say remember that you know
we have very very clear numbers about
when abortions are performed in the
United States the huge majority of
abortions are performed early in
pregnancy so we know that about 85% of
abortions are performed very very early
and that is a good thing we also know
that abortion is much much safer the
earlier that a woman can have one so
it's a simple safe surgical procedure or
medication that you can take early on in
pregnancy and very very safe and simple
and suitable to just taking that in an
office a doctor's office and being able
to do that also it's very important to
understand that the nomination of
Cavanagh really threatens the safety of
abortion in our country because as
abortion gets harder to access and there
are places in our country right now
where it is very very difficult for
women to access abortion the harder it
is to access the later it goes into
pregnancies so when it's difficult to
find an abortion because your insurance
won't cover it because you have to drive
a really long way to get to a place to
have one when you have a waiting period
there are numerous restrictions they've
been just piling up over the last five
to ten years hundreds literally hundreds
of restrictions in the states and so
what that does is it moves the abortion
later into the process and that makes it
less safe so it's in our interest to
make sure that there's access to
abortion in order to help women have
access so that abortion really remains
safe and that's something I hear from my
patients in my practice you know they're
very very grateful to be able to get in
early and take care of themselves in a
way that's going to be safe for them
that's primary on their mind but dr.
Davis this does seem to evade the
question which we're talking about the
safety of abortion the point for people
who
abortion is that abortion is never safe
for the baby who is being killed and so
my question is is there a point not just
at which it's less safe for the woman to
have an abortion say in the third
trimester or I don't know but is there a
point at which the pro-abortion movement
the people who are advocates of abortion
will say after this date if this is
infanticide surely we would all say
killing a baby who's one day old and has
been born for a day that that is not
morally licit but that is a sin and
that's a crime is there a point before
then especially looking now and even
looking at poll numbers of public
opinion on abortions and late term
abortions where the pro-abortion
movement and abortion providers will say
this is not morally licit this is
killing a baby in either the second
trimester or the third trimester
I'd really like to focus more on the
reality of the medical care that we're
actually providing so this is the
reality the babies are it living in
reality I'm not quite sure where your
question is going you know to my mind in
our practice the things that we're
concerned about we're concerned about
making sure people get their care early
that the care is safe those are the
things that are important to my patients
and then I'm dealing with every day the
patients that I took care of this
morning
we really what they're concerned about
is their safety their reproductive
health their fertility their future and
that's what we're really focused on i I
understand the average patient isn't
saying you know this particular number
of days in my pregnancy that's really
not how we look at it every situation
where the pregnancy is going to be
different in terms of the gestational
age and again having abortions later in
pregnancy is really the minority the
majority of people really are facing a
situation where the early in pregnancy
and they need to get the care at that
time abortion is extremely safe if you
compare the risk for instance um of
something extreme like a woman's death a
woman dying during an abortion that is 8
times 6 to 8 more times likely to happen
giving birth so abortion is a very safe
procedure we know that we're always
working
make it safer I'm all about doing
research and practice and changing
practice to even make it safer but we
know that abortion is safe common care
we want to make sure we can keep it that
way and the nomination of Judge Joe but
but dr. dr. Davis respectfully it seems
that you're evading my question because
I'm I am asking a specific question I
understand you say people don't care
that much about the figuring out at what
gestational age killing a baby in the
womb is morally licit
but I am asking about that question
about at what point we could kill that
baby because we say it's a safe
procedure it isn't safe for those babies
and I just want to know you're you
you're perfectly able to answer and say
the abortion movement does not care
about that we do not care about public
opinion which opposes late term
abortions and second trimester abortions
that's not what we're concerned with
you're you're perfectly able to say that
I just want to know if there will be a
moment when the pro-abortion movement
acknowledges that there is a living
human being inside of that woman that is
being snuffed out and killed in the
process of providing a safe abortion to
the woman
well in the conversation I can tell you
what happens in the reality of medical
practice which is in my office I think
that's really where the most important
part of the practice happens now I
didn't wear it out the pants and not in
not between people and theoretical but
really those conversations that happen
between a woman and a doctor or another
provider in her house yes the baby is
not theoretically killed the baby is
killed really and I'm right so when a
woman has an abortion the pregnancy ends
I think we can all understand that that
is exactly what happens when someone has
an abortion so really what we're focused
on is making sure she gets the right
care at the right time and making sure
that she has access to that care and I
suppose then so my follow-up question if
we're talking about care if we're
talking about the the medical realities
of these things we must take into
consideration the Hippocratic oath not
to hurt a patient not to cause harm at
first do no harm
is there any point in the gestational
age of the unborn baby at which you
would treat that unborn baby as a human
patient that you have to care for
medically and physically uh well I think
you know when you talk about the meaning
of things it really depends on the
person her beliefs the beliefs of her
family and what are your beliefs I'm
asking your beliefs as a leader in this
field I am very clear about my beliefs
which is that I'm in full support of a
woman's constitutional right to an
abortion as well as all the other forms
all the way up until the day of birth
are you are you are you saying that you
support the woman's right to an abortion
all the way up through the entire
gestation that's what I'm asking you to
clarify well we're not talking about
gestational limits I think that I am
talking about it that is what I am
talking about in asking specifically do
you support the right to an abortion up
until the day of giving birth my my
personal practice is that I provide care
within the full scope from the law and
in compliance with all the rules and the
laws of my state and my hospital and
that's what concerns me and the care
that I give to my patients is really
primary just like if you were having
surgery really you'd be thinking about
you and what you need for your your
surgery in your health that's really
what's on my mind I don't I don't want
to be labor the Pointer beating a dead
horse I just want to be crystal clear
because I don't want you taken out of
context you've said that you will
provide an abortion up to the legal
limit in your state which could be well
past the age of viability we have
children that have survived and been
viable and gone on to live who were born
at just 21 weeks or 22 weeks in many
states that limit is 26 weeks in some
cases it can be even later but I am
asking you as a matter of not just of
state law I know the state law is not
just a federal law I'm asking you as a
question of the practice of abortion
itself and with your expertise in the
medical field
do you support medically not legally not
politically medically do you support the
the woman's right to an abortion up
until the
day of birth is there any limit on
gestational age at which point you
yourself regardless of the law would say
I will not perform this abortion that's
not a scenario that occurs in my
practice it's not something that I have
to make decisions about because it isn't
a real scenario it is a real scenario
women are pregnant up until the day they
give birth that it's a real scenario
might not be a practical one that you
experience I understand but I think
you're focusing on something that is so
outlandish and bizarre to imply that
people are having abortions the day
before a baby's doctor Davis I'm I'm
using this as an example to take Nia
logical well I'll explain it to you I'm
well I'll explain it to you I am
following the logic of abortion to its
logical conclusions you're saying that
we are disregarding the individual human
life that is being killed in the process
of abortion you were saying that you are
disregarding that as a patient and as a
human being up to a certain point and
I'm just asking you to tell me what that
point is and why and you can't provide
an answer to that no I gave you a clear
answer which is that I provide abortion
up to the limit yes but you that is a
slightly different question so are you
then saying that let's say the limit is
I don't know where your practice is but
let's say the limit is 26 weeks are you
then saying that at 26 weeks in
gestation that baby is a baby and it
would be immoral and wrong to snuff out
its life that is not a conversation that
I have with my patients you know John
would you have it with me last just even
in the last few days I've had
circumstances where we've been looking
at pregnancies that have gone it gotten
very medically complicated and you know
imagine that something like this happens
to you where you're at a certain don't
think it's gonna happen to me or my
manager that happens to someone in your
family or a friend of yours and these
things do happen all the time you know
human reproduction is not perfect so
things happen where conditions develop
either with how the women can get
very very critically ill when they're
pregnant doctor Davis we would agree the
vast vast majority of abortions occur
things can happen with fetal development
so we're in a situation where we have to
make sure we're following the law
we're following best practices and we're
doing the right thing for that woman it
isn't necessarily about whether it's
this many days or that many days of
course that's important it's important
to her it's important to me but really
my main concern is to give the good
medical care that people need and I
don't want to get into the details of
anyone's scenario because that's a
person talked about that happen here
every day of the week we have patients
in scenarios where they have complicated
care we're providing very advanced care
to them to really to save their lives
and we need to have the flexibility to
give the right care at the right time in
whatever stage in we can in the full
practice of being in compliance with our
local laws that's really what my job's
about I understand it I'll let you go
I've taken up a lot of your time but I
do want to bring up one point which as
you mentioned the threats to the life of
the woman and surely we can agree the
the numbers are in that the vast vast
vast majority of abortions that take
place over 99% of abortions do not
concern cases of rape or incest or
threat to the life of the mother which
brings me to my last question again in
your work not so much as a doctor but as
a consultant to the the physicians for
reproductive health which is that we
know from dr. Bernard Nathanson the guy
who founded nay roll the biggest
pro-abortion organization in the country
and who ran the largest abortion clinic
in the country for two years we know
that the number that we're constantly
told women will die women will thousands
of women died per year from illegal
abortions before roe v wade this is this
has come up in judicial hearings from
Bork all the way up to the present we
hear it every single time a Republican
nominates a judge we know from him the
man who invented that statistic that it
was plucked out of thin air he admitted
it he said quote in a row we generally
emphasize the frame of the individual
case not the mass statistics but when we
spoke of the latter it was always five
or ten thousand deaths a year I can
that I knew the figures were totally
false and I suppose that others did too
if they stop to think of it but in the
morality of our Revolution it was a
useful figure widely accepted so why go
out of our way to correct it with honest
statistics the overriding concern was to
get the laws eliminated anything within
reason that had to be done was
permissible we know from the Centers for
Disease Control that the year before roe
v-- wade was decided the actual number
of women who died from illegal abortions
was 39 the number of women who died from
legal abortions was 24 abortion was only
legal in 20 states which means
statistically both legal and illegal
abortions were about as risky as one
another moving forward in this debate
will end in these judicial hearings will
the abortion movement stop the
demonstrable lie that thousands of women
will die per year.if roe v-- wade is
overturned well they stopped that or
will they continue to harp on that and I
ask you personally if you've ever had
any of the thoughts or skepticism or
pauses that Bernard Nathanson has had
with regard to the the moral quality of
the activity that you're doing I don't
mean this to demagogue I don't mean this
to be rude in any way but if we're if
we're talking about what we're talking
about which is is this baby a moral
being
does it have moral significance human
dignity does it have moral weight is it
okay to snuff it out if there's a 5%
chance that that is true if there's a
10% chance if there's a 95% chance how
sure are you and does the activity of
abortion give you pause a lot of
questions in there you know I love
numbers I have master's degree in public
health and I'm a researcher so I'm very
happy to look at numbers and think about
numbers and I'm not in charge of a
messaging for a movement I'm a doctor
and I am an also a patient advocate and
you're a patient advocate which is why
which is why I like your public opinion
what I want to
say that when we look at numbers like
how many people died before abortion was
legal and how many people died after
abortion was legal I think it's very
easy to understand the difference
between illegal abortion and legal
abortion back in you know decades ago
that there really were not methods
available to people that were safe many
they were equally risky and
statistically speaking just as many
women died from legalism abortions so
when we talk to doctors who were
practicing before abortion was legal it
was very common for women to come into
the emergency room critically ill wind
up with a hysterectomy they may not have
died but there was a lot of serious
morbidity losing their fertility nearly
losing their life having emergency
operations and those were routine things
there were whole wards and hospitals
dedicated to trying to save women's
lives after attempts at illegal abortion
those things don't exist anymore and
they didn't exist after abortion became
legal so you don't need a whole lot of
very particular numbers to understand
that things got a lot a lot so it seems
to me the numbers clarify thing is
better than the anecdotes - I agree but
when you take when you're trying to
count something that's illegal right
it's super hard to do that and how do
you count somebody dying you write
something on a death certificate if it's
a circumstance where something is highly
stigmatized it's pretty hard to count
and what you see on a death certificate
may have nothing to do with what
actually happened maybe it says the
patient died of septic shock but it was
as a result of an illegal abortion Lee
but doctor we do we do have statistics
in crime we collect statistics on crime
very well do so I think we know you know
I think we know from common sense in
terms of the practice and observing the
practice what happened that's not
something that was that was something
that was very very well documented and
even colleagues you know 10 years ago
some of those doctors are older now but
they told us what it was like and these
were people working in major medical
centers in the United States so there
were people that faced this and that
really was the backbone of trying to
make sure that abortion became safe
because so many women were injured and
even lost their lives that's not
something we want to see come back again
you can argue about whether or not
things would be different now that we
have different abortion methods it may
be that illegal abortion may not be as
physically unsafe for a woman but keep
in mind that if abortion becomes illegal
there are new risks right there are
risks for people like me who provide it
there are risks for patients in terms of
taking medication what do you mean there
were risks people like you rated for
ending a pregnancy if Rho is overturned
so those things are real concerns for us
we're very concerned about that as to my
last question doctor you you don't have
to answer it you're under no obligation
to but considering the example of dr.
Bernard Nathanson among others major not
only abortionists abortion providers
heads of abortion clinics and abortion
advocates who have totally changed their
position we regularly see this people
who supported abortion rights who then
became pro-life this happened to me
myself and I was convinced by a
bioethicists to change my opinion I
previously thought abortion was
perfectly permissible has the subject
ever given you pause even if you are not
going to conclude that a baby in the
womb is with 100% certainty and moral
being worthy of dignity and respect and
the protection of life would you be
willing to grant that there's perhaps an
80% chance or a 20% chance or even a 2%
chance that that baby in the womb has
moral value
I don't put percents on my morality I'm
gonna ask you what I'm doing and I'm
very clear about the care that I give
and that's what's important to me is my
patients and that they get the right
medical care from me and that's where
that's where I put my efforts that's
where I've been practicing for 20 years
that's why I got my training that's why
I teach young doctors to provide the
care that I do really so that women get
the best care that they can and that
should be a priority for everybody well
doctor I have to thank you for coming on
not a lot of people who were on the left
will come on my show and very few people
who are in your position are willing to
speak to conservative outlets so I
certainly have to thank you for doing
that and I'll and I'll be praying for
you
okay and welcome the opportunity thank
you thank you dr. Davis thank you
Wow I know we ran really long but I I
just I can't believe it it's an amazing
thing when you have the opportunity for
that sort of conversation because she
just won't accept each she won't even
acknowledge the premise she wouldn't
even acknowledge the premise is there
any chance that this human life that we
know is a human life it's not a platypus
and it's not dead it's a human life is
there any chance that that has moral
significance she wouldn't even
acknowledge the premise I think that
tells you everything you need to know
about the abortion debate we'll try to
get to a couple mailbag questions if you
were on Daily wire.com thank you very
much you help us keep the lights on Eco
FFA in my cup if you are on Facebook or
YouTube
we definitely got censored after that
discussion that was far too frank and
honest' a discussion to possibly be
allowed to be head on social media pages
so please go to daily wire.com it's ten
bucks a month 100 dollars for an annual
membership you get me you get the indra
Clavin sure you get the Ben Shapiro show
you had to ask questions in the mailbag
although this week you only get to ask
like two because we ran a little late in
our conversation and you get to ask
questions in the conversation speaking
of which will next time have been
Shapiro the big boss himself none of
that matters
you need the Cory Booker vintage you
need it you need it he's running for
president senator Cornyn's said it today
he's running for president we're gonna
need to make a bigger vessel we're gonna
need a bigger boat we're gonna need a
bigger vessel when Cory Booker runs for
president go to daily wire.com get your
tumblr we'll be right back with the
mailbag
[Music]
I'm gonna burn through as many of these
as I can all right I'm fired up from
Matt Michael I just finished your book
reasons to vote for Democrats I loved it
but I had a question could you elaborate
more on what you meant by and I quote
looking forward to your response I on it
obviously when I wrote there was an
exoteric meaning which it seems you've
picked up on and there also is an
esoteric meaning for those for those
great readers for those best of men who
can understand the conversation
that I'm having with the ancients but I
couldn't possibly explain it more
clearly for fear of persecution in the
art of writing from Donna dear Michael
you're a millennial born in New York
attended Yale are a relative of Hillary
Clinton with a name like Beyonce and
looks like Rachel Maddow with all of
that how in the world did you become a
conservative I think that's why isn't
that why that's got to be why
conservatives tend to be a little
contrarian in our culture a conservative
is contrarian we stand at word history
yelling stop and if you're willing to
weather the slings and arrows of that in
our culture you're certainly contrarian
so I actually do think there is
something to that if you grew up in all
these crazy places and you look like
Rachel Maddow why would you become more
conservative it's part of it I used to
fear that if I grew up in the middle of
Texas I'd be a communist or something
but I don't think that's true
the I I was born with like hair parted
smoking a cigar you know reading the The
Wall Street Journal or something that is
dried did that from a young age but I
went through a little lefty period when
I was in high school I think a lot of
teenagers do that I went through my
atheist phase from 13 to 23 or so but
about 10 years and it was great to come
out of that you know a bill Whittle has
this great idea that like when you don't
know anything you're a Democrat and then
when you know a little bit you're a or
when you don't know anything you're a
Republican when you know a little bit
you're a Democrat and then when you know
more you become a Republican again I
think there is something like that you
got to go through the fire of it and
then you come back out part of it is
that the left is
so insane that people who aren't like me
to the right of Attila the Hun people
who are like David Rubin have come over
to the right as well because they sure
can't stay on the left there's no room
for them in the Democrat Party the I was
a conservative before I had any
religious views again so I don't know
that you have to have those religious
views but once you accept the reality of
Christianity or Judaism or whatever your
theistic religious views are it's very
hard if you follow those ideas to their
logical conclusions it's very hard to
remain a leftist because the left has
totally embraced materialism has totally
embraced a scientistic materialist
worldview that precludes any sense of
meaning and the human soul and sin and
grace and redemption so I think I think
that will also help bring people back
over as well but as for me I don't know
I came I came out puffing a cigar from
Timothy what is your favorite CS Lewis
book and why thanks Michael from the
block
that's my when I run against Ocasio
Cortese that's gonna be my nickname
Michael from the block you don't you
know you know I don't even remember the
lyrics to quote them my favorite Lewis
books it's really hard to pick - your
Christianity and abolition of man are my
two favorites your Christianity is
essential reading abolition of man is
terrifically wonderful reading but wait
if Gloria's great miracles paint problem
of pain a grief observed they're also so
good I love them all I haven't read the
Narnia books I don't really God from
friends of mine don't really like his
novels so and I don't read novels that
much but those two at least are good to
start with when we've got time for one
or two more from Corey hey Michael I've
been looking more and more toward the
Catholic faith what would you say to
convince someone that Jesus Christ not
only existed but was also the Son of God
to be 100% honest I enjoy your show far
more than any other daily wire podcast
yeah baby keep up the good work Corey
all right good stuff Corey that you're
you're asking that question in that way
is one great evidence of God that's good
evidence of grace and Providence okay
I'll put it this I'm trying to figure
out which step you should go through
first I'll just tell you how I came to
it I the arguments for God are much
better than the arguments against God I
don't think there's really any
compelling argument against the
existence of God except perhaps for the
problem of pain which ends up and
suffering which ends up becoming one of
the great arguments for the existence of
God
so we grant the existence of God then
the question that you have to grapple
with is what sort of God is it you have
to grapple with the person of Jesus
Christ and this is one of the great
arguments for Christianity is that it
really happened
it's not just a poem it's not just a
philosophy it begins with journalism it
begins with a fact the fact of God being
incarnate being in fleshed coming into
the world living in the world having a
body working with his hands teaching
suffering under Pontius Pilate being
crucified dying being buried rising
again from the dead you have to ask
yourself who this person of Christ is
one or these accounts that we have of
him reliable they certainly seem to be
very few historians would suggest that
there's no there was no historical
person of Jesus that that the historical
narrative we have of Jesus is radically
different from his actual life I don't
know of anybody who would really say
that it's certainly no serious person so
then you have to look at the Gospels
which are good texts and narratives of
the life of Christ and say do they line
up do they seem to line up with reality
sometimes people try to disprove the the
historicity of Christ by saying the
Gospel accounts a vary a little bit the
some say he was here at this day and
then he was there or what you know right
that's actually an argument for the
historicity of Christ if this were just
made up by some conspiracy and they were
writing a legend there wouldn't be any
discrepancies just consider the
difference between a novel and a
newspaper in a novel you don't have any
discrepancies because it was all thought
out in a fiction the newspapers disagree
with each other every day because you're
talking about real facts that people see
and if they're written 30 years later or
20 years later there might be some
discrepancies so that's I think is
actually an argument for the historicity
of Christ to say nothing of the rest of
the New Testament and other other
historians of that time who would
describe Christ and the writers of the
patristic era and the Acts of the
Apostles another argument for it is that
the Apostles gave their lives for Christ
just spread Church these were people who
knew Jesus who saw him rise from the
dead who went to the ends of the earth
we know that they went to the ends of
the earth to attest to this and to be
killed for it we know that they went all
the way to Rome we know that they went
all the way east to socotra and India my
confirmations say Thomas went all the
way to India where he was killed
it could compare the founding of Islam
in Christianity Islam was founded by
people who spread their religion with
the sword
Christianity was spread by people who
spread their religion and had their
heads chopped off who spread their
religion in spite of the sword and ended
up meeting the sword at the end it is
very hard to convince me that those
people were just in on a really funny
joke a joke that was so funny that they
were willing to give their lives
immediately to leave their boats to
leave their communities and follow
Christ all the way to the ends of the
earth and all the way to death very hard
for me to believe that which is which is
the more compelling explanation it seems
to me that the fact of Christianity is
true and the fact that it is a fact is a
good argument for thee for the truth of
it okay that's all we've got time for I
know I ran late sorry too bad I don't
even get sorry I'm not sorry hashtag
sorry I'm not sorry
make sure you binge another Kingdom
because we're recording season 2 it's
really really good season one is still
available for you to binge and there's a
new one it's going to be even better so
get ready for that otherwise I'll see on
Monday I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael nul show have a good weekend
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you